right uh
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to tonight's planning committee
my name is bill fleming and i'm going to
be chairman of the committee this
evening
before we get started a little bit of
housekeeping
committee members when invited address
the meeting please ensure your
microphone is switched on so that it's
picked up via the live audio feed
when you've finished addressing the
meeting please turn off your microphone
immediately
please ensure you've switched off or to
silent any other devices you may have
that may interrupt the proceedings
we have a live broadcast
please note this meeting is also being
broadcast live and members of the public
not in attendance today are able to view
these
proceedings with me today are members of
the committee and democratic services
officer olivia quinn
uh solicitor mason nash
we have richard gardner planning manager
and uh
louise casey
teddy horton yeah sorry about that um
i think you have something to say before
we sort of get going haven't we
yes thanks mr chairman um that's just to
confirm my role tonight which is to
provide impartial advice to committee
members and to assist them in their
decision taking thank you
okay thank you we'll go straight on to
the agenda item number one apologies for
our absence
chair we've got apologies from
councillors adam curtis kendall and
richards
okay
thank you very much for that
have any interest i'd like to declare in
relation to item
yeah yeah it's working thank you
um i'm a county council uh
councillor and nupton is in my ward
um welcome to this meeting with an open
mind
thank you very much for that
minutes
uh do i have a proposal and a second or
for the minutes included with the agenda
okay thank you everybody happy with that
yeah
okay
you're not a master
thank you chairman
there's the context map of the site it's
in napton on the hill which is a
category 2 local service village
which lies within the ironstone hills
fringe special landscape area
the
application site is for the arc school
so you can see there are a number of
this is off vicarage road in knutson
the school is a specialist primary
school for children with certain
education and social needs you can see
there are a number of residential
properties surrounding the site
to the south there's the barn
hounton's farm
and to the north there
hillcrest which are long established
residential properties and then more
recent development through collins close
to the southeast and walnut tree house
to the northeast
so the slide here on the left hand side
is a site layout plan
of the scheme that was granted planning
permission
elements of that that were given
permission and can be implemented
are a large freestanding classroom here
a wet poor play area here
three
teaching pods
here and then various
paths through the existing grassed area
play area that the children use
so what's before members this evening is
an application to vary that previous
permission
in three main respects
so in no order of importance
element one here is a slightly re-routed
path
so if you can compare it to the the arcs
path here it's it's slightly sharper
turn
element two here is a relocated wet pore
play area which originally was down the
southern boundary here and it's now
relocated to the northern boundary here
and then element three are the three
teaching pods so two changes here one is
to the location orientation of those so
they're previously in this orientation
they're now parallel to the southern
boundary and then secondly slight
increase in size to the larger of those
pods and increases in size to the two
smaller pods
in terms of the classroom elements that
stays as previously permitted and has
not been applied for to be changed and
neither are any of the other paths on
that diagram
in terms of the pods on the left hand
side are the pods as previously
granted permission by the committee
and on the right hand side are the
slightly enlarged pods so on the top
there the two smaller pods
increase in size from what was 2.4
meters by 3 meters to now become
3 meters by five meters
and on the bottom slide there this
element here the increase in size is
from three meters three meters by four
meters to now be three meters by six
meters so effectively two meter
extension in length
the height of the permitted and
applied four pods remains the same at
2.4
meters
there's a photograph of the pods the
application is retrospective so you can
see them
in place as existing
so that's
uh set off from the southern boundary so
the property behind is hounton's farm
you can see there on the hard standing
where previously there were temporary
buildings which have been removed
and they do not interfere with the car
parking or
vehicle maneuvering areas of the site
moving to this slide these slides which
show the wet poor area uh
up against the northern boundary of the
site and in the background there we have
walnut tree house
so there's a caveat i need to
highlight here in that the application
before members this evening
is only related to the wet pour area on
the slides and not any of the play
equipment
the applicants have decided that they
wish to deal with the play equipment
separately to the wet poor area this is
something which is allowable through the
planning process you can make more than
one application or more than one process
to seek permission
and that's what the applicants have
sought to do so
those elements of the play equipment the
swing the climbing frame with the slide
are not before members this evening to
grant or refuse it is simply
the hard standing wet pour area that is
the element that is being applied for
via this application
and then some more photographs so the
top two photographs
pan around to the east eastern boundary
so in the background there you have the
collins close
developments
this is the area where the freestanding
classroom is going but that's not
changed since the previous permission so
not to be considered this evening and
then panning around here
to the southern boundary so you've got
the start of the barn residential
property and then along the bottom here
looking along the southern boundaries
you've got the barn property
the aggressed area here is where the
permission
currently is for the wet paw play area
as i say it's now been moved to the
north and that's what's been sought as
the change to that
and then that just gives a kind of
google
maps overview of the site and the
surrounding properties
chairman the
key issues in this case really relate to
the impacts of the three teaching pods
the real line path and the wet poor play
area
on the immunity of neighbouring
residential properties
in terms of noise
disturbance and privacy
taking into account the circumstances
of the previous permission
taking into account the existing use of
the site as a school with a grassed area
where children can use
taking into account the lack of any
objection from the environmental health
officer
then officers recommend grant planning
permission
subject to the skeletal skeletal
conditions set out in the report thank
you
thank you uh
totally thank you for that
right
oh crikey
hey
yeah well
right out we'll go on to the uh we've
got two speakers registered on this item
and uh the first one to speak would be
councillor rachel pelter nupton parish
council
objecting is she's
here
to come and take a seat and
you've got three minutes
i don't have the timing machine oh you
got it okay um you've got three minutes
we'll give you a nod when you've got 30
seconds left
and
we'll
stay where you are when you're finished
there may well be some questions thank
you very much
napton parish council objects to this
application which is complicated by
several versions of its plans
however the standout issue is the
contentious relocation of the wet paw
play area without consultation or
approval
the original application stated this
would be
formed within the existing grassed play
area to the rear of the school
instead it has been located without
permission directly adjacent to the
boundary fence of a neighboring property
in addition to the wet ball climbing
frame has been erected in the same
location which offers a clear view not
only into the neighbour's garden but
also into the bedroom of one of the
residents
the parish council respectfully reminds
the planning committee that the children
attending art school have found learning
difficult in mainstream settings and
that this is a specialized teaching
environment with people displaying a
variety of educational and behavioral
needs
emotional dysregulation means their use
of language tone and volume can be
challenging and sometimes intimidating
other neighbours have reported items
being thrown into gardens and pets and
young children have only just avoided
injury
all of these issues have a serious
negative impact on neighbour immunity
in p to their lawful environment of
their property and compromises the
security of their families
the parish council submits that this
retrospective application is not in
accordance with the following
stratfor district council's core
strategy
policies c9 design design and
distinctiveness point b8 that proposals
will protect occupants of neighbouring
buildings from unacceptable levels of
noise and a lot of privacy
policy as-10 of core strategy and the
requirement to minimize the impact on
the occupiers and users of existing
properties in the area
plus from napton's neighborhood
development plan
policy for business development point b
because it overlooks an adjoining
property
policy for point g because the impact in
terms of noise is not acceptable
policy 5 and environmental quality point
b
as design features have not been
incorporated to protect the tranquility
of the area
the fencing remains picket style with
open slats
policy 12
local services and community facilities
because of the detrimental impact on
their neighbors privacy and use of
garden
in addition the staff at the school
regularly park in dangerous and
unsuitable locations in the village and
despite many requests by the parish
council this inconsiderate behavior
continues
the original permission for the new and
relocation of classrooms 30 seconds was
granted by this committee but with a
number of associated conditions for
example the erection of netting along
the boundary fence
the parish council is concerned that a
number of these conditions have not been
met and yet the applicant has continued
to do work on site without the required
permissions
the article has a display board outside
its main gates and much is made of them
wanting to make a positive impact on the
local community and have been the best
neighbors we can be
the parish council concerns that these
actions are not those of a good
neighbour and do not have a positive
impact on our community
okay i'm just about to call time does
have you finished oh that's good timing
then thank you very much
um does anybody have any questions for
the counsellor
okay tony come on
thank you chairman
uh cather pelter um the relocation of
the poor wet area in its current
position where it is has permission
would it be simply impacting upon the
property known as the barn and therefore
is it a change of which property is
being impacted as such or is there or
was the bar not going to be impacted in
the current location
do you mean walnut house yeah
well
look at the plan we've
if he's moving from the south
there yet but probably labeled here is
the barn next to the story
is there a
house farm
sorry yeah because i haven't got it
[Applause]
from there
so that's that's
not one's currently
i'm sorry so that's the house then it
goes to there right now
i think possibly but not necessarily
because
i think that bomb bit there is not the
same as the house and my yeah my
understanding is that it's it was more
central and now it's absolutely
on the face yeah
anybody have any other questions for the
thank you counseling uh you mentioned
that it would be overlooking the
property obviously we're not
um we don't take into account on this
application declining frames so if
you're standing there
how are you overlooking the property
just you can see through i mean if i
think when you look at the pictures it's
the open slats because it's a picket fan
so there's some
flowers and shrubs etc um obviously it's
worth it as a climbing frame but you
would still be able to see through the
stats to a certain extent it may depend
on the height of the child etc but it is
let's answer your question
yes thank you very much okay
anybody else have any questions
nope
um second speaker we have is mr john
veazey
uh resident
i take a seat mr veazey
it doesn't matter which one
right
like before you've got three minutes
we'll give you a shout when we're
30 seconds from the end
and uh
if you stay there we may well have some
questions for you at the end so
uh your three minutes starts now and off
we've got some slides there and and uh
sorry this is probably not part of my
time but when i raise my hand can you
so the objection concerns the wet poor
soft play area and the direct effect it
is having on my family's quality of life
our privacy and our loss of immunity
under the original application the play
area was more than 50 meters away from
the boundary fence so we did not raise
any concerns however the play area was
installed in its current location during
the summer holidays without permission
or consultation
this variant seeks to normalize that
location
so slide one shows the open nature of
the the fence that's between us and the
fence belongs to the school
if you go to slide two please
now i realize that the play equipment is
not being considered under this
application however the two
able to separate them however that is a
an issue for the committee
slide three please oh you are you're
already there um
sorry so what i've done is highlighted
there that there's a child looking
through the fence
and from that position you can see into
my mother-in-law's bedroom
and she's rather an elderly lady and if
she's getting changed or dressed she she
can be observed
in stratford district's core strategy
has a number of policies which are
applicable to consider in these
situations
and they were considered in conjunction
with the original application the full
this is a variance against but do not
appear to have been taken into account
correctly
um on on the variants
so these policies and i'm not going to
repeat them in full as10
uh cs9 section b8
um and
um
i seem to have a piece of paper missing
um under the napton um
core strat sorry under the knapton
neighborhood development plan policy 12
also covers this and says that there
should be protection for residents from
um
unnecessary noise and
um
in loss of amenity
we have lived in our in
conjunction with art school for 10 years
at walnut treehouse and we have never
complained about the noise before but
since the arrival of the wet paw play
area it has concentrated all the
activity on the school playing field in
that location immediately adjacent to
the fence
and this has had a serious and a
debilitating effect on
our health and our our
abilities to function as a family
um and it contravenes
policies thank you
thank you very much well within the time
right
does anybody have any questions
for mr beezy okay councillor crump
hello mr easy
um
just going to regarding the nature of
the wet paw
um i would assume
because of the way it's constructed it's
more usable than the rest of the area
when in times of rain and so it's
is it more being used more often
than the other parts of the playing
field area
yes i think that's a fair assumption
it's difficult to actually put a time
scale on whatever it is but certainly
there's a lot of activity takes place my
office is uh
where this photograph on the screen was
taken from
looking downwards and there is activity
immediately adjacent to the fence for
um that the school is in progress for
six hours a day um the pupils are there
for six hours a day and i would say that
for up to four hours there is activity
play activity on the wet poor area
irrespective of whether they're using
the equipment
thank you i hope that answers your
question thank you
thank you for that any other questions
ah
go counselor milks thank you very much
um
did you say your mother-in-law lives yes
i think it lives downstairs she has a an
integral apartment on the ground floor
on the ground so that's they
so they can be she can be observed from
yes correction thank you very much the
grant the topography of the ground is
that the the school is higher than we
are so they're tending to look down on
us
okay
matt yeah come on
when you're looking at the window here
to the left there's another school
building isn't there correct um how much
noise do you get from that
generally there hadn't been a lot um
it's um it's separated from the main
part of the school by a a six foot high
metal fence
it goes around the two buildings that
are shown
if you remember on the plan and i don't
know whether it's possible to go back to
the plan of the school site might be
easy for me to explain
if that's possible
um
yeah so that one there where the the new
building is proposed to be if you can
see there's two existing buildings and
there's a small fence
line shown there
that runs around
those two buildings in the bottom those
children tend to be very very young
children
and they're highly supervised um
i i would suggest that there's a ratio
of almost one to one between
uh pupils and staff so
typically there hasn't been a great deal
of noise and again until the advent of
the wet poor area and what happens now
is there is communication and quite a
lot of communication between the
children
within the fence and the children
playing on the wet poor area
i hope does that answer your question
it does just because i i need to ask
another question but i'm not sure
whether you'd know the age of the
children at the school
but or whether i'd
i think they go up to 11.
okay thank you very much okay
okay thank you very much
okay that's it you're done
uh thank you very much chairman and good
evening everybody
there are two main elements here the
teaching pods in the play area which i
think you're probably gathered by now
although there's a minor increase in the
size of pods
there and there has been some worry
locally about expanding use of the site
generally i accept the assurance that
such bigger pods will not significantly
increase activity so the pods aren't the
issue of contention
can i slide while we've got it already
the problem is the relocation of the
so-called wet plate wet pore plate
surface and by application the
associated equipment on it this is a
retrospective application to vary the
previous approved application
uh in its previous location it was not a
problem uh and and by the way i believe
the barn is not a separate dwelling i
believe it's ancillary accommodation for
the hounton's farm
this new location is a problem
the play area is close to the residence
called bournemouth treehouse as we've
already heard
and as you can see from these pictures
it's very close and the top right
picture is the one that's taken from the
ground floor bedroom of the elderly lady
that lives in the house and as has been
said it's lower than the area
now our planning advice note calls for
special attention in protecting private
spaces such as gardens and windows
and this site has shown the potential
to originate more nuisance and loss of
privacy than would a window to a
habitable room in an adjacent house if
there were to be one
of slide two please
[Laughter]
um
so if if that was uh
such a such a uh
habitable room with a window that would
not be permitted within 21 meters rather
than this 15 and a half meters that this
uh this distance is
now planning officers have noted the
advice of the environmental health
officer that intimate intermittent high
noise levels would not constitute a
statutory news nuisance if not sustained
over a longer period
after discussion with paul reed head of
environmental services i am advised that
the thresholds for the right to private
enjoyment of property and that of a
statutory noise nuisance are not the
same and the committee is empowered to
judge this on a wider basis could have
slide 3 please
you will see from the first page of the
report that this is an area of high
archaeological interests and a
pre-commencement investigation was
required
but the construction work has already
been done and any archaeology already
been lost
similarly there were a number of other
pre-commencement conditions to protect
root systems secure the fences drainage
and levels
as far as i can see none of these have
been met and present a problem now to
resolve
it is clear from these pictures that the
play facility was and is intended to
comprise the surface and the climbing
equipment in a unified installation all
done at the same time
yet for reasons unclear the applicants
have failed to show on drawings or apply
for the equipment despite being advised
by the planning and planning enforcement
teams that permission for the whole
installation is required
it's frankly bizarre that you are being
asked to consider one without the other
the residents have been at pains to
point out they have had no issue with
the recreational areas when they were
spread across the whole area of the site
but this new facility concentrates the
activity noise and intrusion into one
spot close to their private spaces in
bedrooms
particularly the ground floor for the
elderly person's accommodation
the variation moves the play area and
its consequential noise and nuisance
source as pos as close as possible to
walnut tree house
i cannot see that as-10 has been met
where it says all proposals will need to
minimize impact on the occupiers and
users of existing properties in the area
i'm afraid i have to disagree with the
officer's conclusion in respect of the
play area which is in conflict of
knapton enabled development plan
policies for b g 5b 12a as well as as10
i ask that you approve the pods but not
the play service and i hope the
applicant will remove the surface and
the equipment from this location
thank you chairman
thank you very much council rock does
anybody have any questions
for council rock
you got off lightly there so it would
appear
now we've heard from all the speakers um
point to clarification i think please oh
look at that okay
okay
guys the james was first okay
i'm presuming council rock has just
mentioned that um he'd be happy for her
to approve
the pods but not
the um
wet paw play area but i don't think
that's within i just want to clarify
that that's not within our our gift we
have to judge us all on one
on the planning application in front of
us
yes that's absolutely absolutely right
you're unable to split it off and uh
start refusing parts and granting other
parts so it has to all
stand as one
counter addiction yeah
thank you chairman uh tony um i may have
missed it in the report if i did i'm
sorry were did have the applicants given
the reason why they're wanting to put
the wet play area in that location as
opposed to the approved location
there's nothing i've seen which just
which set an applicant's justification
for that so i i can't i can't speak for
them and they're not here to speak for
themselves
okay thank you casey mills
thanks mr chairman tony tony um
should they have sought permission to
[Music]
to move the um the play at this play
area should they sought permission to do
this before
or not
yes they they the planning permission
that was granted which on the left-hand
side puts the player the wet poor play
area to the southern boundary
they've moved it to the northern
boundary but without the correct
planning permissions without correct
planning permission okay which is what
this application is
the fencing condition
um
what is normal on a fencing condition
um
and
how enforceable well obviously it's
enforceable because it could go to the
enforcement officer but what's the
maximum height
um
which we could justifiably ask for
in terms of the fencing
that was put on the original permission
so
where my cursor is because there was the
new classroom going in this location
here
the environmental health officer asked
for an acoustic fence noise barrier to
be going around this part of the site
now that wasn't proposed for any other
part of the site
so there's no change to the rest of that
boundary
along there or to the northern boundary
it was purely the
eastern boundary where because of the
proximity of the classroom
and some air conditioning units
the previous permission
sought to have an acoustic fence there
and there's a that was to be conditioned
for
implementation which would be put on the
same condition put on this
uh application if it was granted and
there's also a secondary element to that
fencing which is to have some netting
above there along the southern bound
eastern boundary i think to stop
balls or um toys being thrown over
okay to follow that one up then
could we condition
um
should we decide that that's the
suitable thing to do on the northern
boundary an acoustic
is that something which we're able to
condition
uh potentially we could condition uh
boundary treatments
um
but it might
mean that it's uh we're conditioning
something that needs permission in its
own right so i don't know richard if you
want to comment on that
um it would need permission if it was
above two meters so you can't condition
something that then needs planning
permission so um
firstly i should say you'd need a
planning justification for that
condition so you'd have to have grounds
for what it what harm it causes without
the fence and then
that would be the justification for the
fence but
above two meters you wouldn't be able to
condition it because it would need
permission in itself
but we could condition up to two meters
that's right yes
okay thank you
tony here coming
sorry chairman another question if i
made tony um
the barn which is the one that i uh was
commenting on as being
the closest building at least to the
existing uh agreed site
council rock indicated that he thought
it was ancillary accommodation to
houghton's farm are we able to confirm
that
i'm not not able to but ancillary
accommodation would have the same
protection in terms of residential
immunity to to the main part of the
house
do we know if there's any windows or
anyhow what the
distances are between the approved
location of the website and that
property
the
that's the the barn
so it does have windows um and it's
cartilage immediately adjacent to the
boundary
i can't say definitively
exactly where it is but it's in this
kind of area where the wet paw was if i
just go back to the layout plans
so
let us zoom in on
the permitted scheme
fortunately the barn property is not
shown but it's in this location so
it's relatively close to that boundary
where the barn is which would be
somewhere around here
if you take that existing building
as the
potential
marker
let's just go back to the photographs
so that's that that's the existing
building there and then the barn here so
the wet paw play area is roughly in in
these kind of locations
thank you chairman um
because of the
issue regarding the fence being two
meters high above 2 meters high that
would require planning permission so
therefore we are limited
with a condition of two meters
if we were minded to agree this and if
we felt it was an appropriate
condition
however we haven't got the information
as far as i can to see to say that a two
meter fence will be appropriate and
reasonable and will fulfill its needs
because
we've got pictures there we've seen it
the topography that the school was
higher than
the next-door neighbor so we might be
putting an offense there that's complete
waste of time
so
would that be
a reasonable condition to put forward
if we haven't got the information to
justify its need or that it will fulfill
its requirements
in that case could you clarify and
confirm what the height is of the
existing fence
i can't say with certainty it appears to
be the standard 1.8 meter high fence
okay
so one other bit it's just
um
is
in the application did it has it
stated anywhere about what times this
play area is in use or is it in constant
use all day
well we've heard from a neighbor who
said
that it's in use for perhaps four four
hours a day my information about the
school opening is as follows
so obviously that the school is only
open during term times um
but as i understand it
they have uh break times
in the morning and the afternoon for
between 10 and 20 minutes and they have
a lunch time break
for one hour between 12 and 1 o'clock
my notes do say that break times can
vary but that
is information that's come from the
school that the case officer
achieved
thank you very much
and again it's about use of the wet pool
area
so are you saying tony that you know
that the pool area is only being used at
break time
and lunch time it's not good being used
for any other educational activity
during non-break times
i can't confirm or clarify that it may
be that it is used at all the times but
those are the the normal break time
periods
but again we've heard from
the the neighbor and i've got no reason
to disbelieve him that
the site has been used for at least four
hours a day and i would imagine
the lunch time and the breaks times
going to quite the four hours
that corrects the the lunchtime and the
the break times would be perhaps one and
a half maybe two hours for extended uh
morning and afternoon periods uh not the
four hours that was quoted but i don't
know what evidence that that's based on
thank you very much then if that's the
case we're going to
move on to
members debate
okay
crikey tony was quick go on
thank you chairman
uh i've got no problem with the pods i
don't think councillor rock's got the
problem with the pods and i don't think
the parish council got a problem with
the pods
but we obviously have a single
application before us ultimately the
decision tonight from my understanding
correct me if i'm wrong is that if it if
the application came in in its current
format and layout
initially
would we approve it or not
if we would reject it because of the
impact upon the neighbours we should
refuse this amendment in the event that
we would be happy with all those
locations we would approve it
given the situation regarding the
ancillary building or not of the barn
looking at the pictures and i think the
topography of the site the barn is above
and higher than the school grounds and
therefore
there wouldn't be to my mind any looking
by
pupils from the school into windows of
the barn they're possibly looking up but
they would not be looking into
when the topography is the other way
around
they're looking from the higher school
down onto a property which is near to
that school and i don't think we should
or would have approved the location of a
play area that close to that that
perhaps that dwelling in the initial
application and i will not be supporting
the officer's recommendation on this one
i think it should be refused
okay thank you very much for that
council jennings first and then cancer
mills
yeah and i don't think anyone's got a
problem with the pods at all um
it's disappointing to me that this
application didn't have a
acoustic fencing
put in
um to protect the new neighbors
um
where this
wet
poor play area is going to be
um
if it had been
then i would have i would certainly
be in in favor of this but well that's
kind of put a damper on it from my point
of view okay
no proposal at this stage
okay
okay okay so milk
thanks mr chairman yeah i'm just
concerned about the privacy um you could
see the children looking through that
fence and uh
i can imagine people sitting in their
gardens
um wouldn't be too happy about this i'm
just concerned about the privacy mr
chairman
um
and also i'm concerned where it is
placed so anyway i'll uh i'll listen to
the rest of the debate thank
you okay thank you all right
peter i said i'll come come across the
university
right i i do have uh reservations that
people
do
these sort of things without planning
permission and also
i feel for the residents
i feel that where it was
existing was the appropriate place to be
so i will agree with tony
on that and
go against the officer's recommendation
okay thank you
thank you mr chairman yeah i
i'm disappointed with this application
if it was just the pods yeah i've got no
problems with it so if they were going
to break it in into two or three to the
pods yeah that have been approved but
this this has been built in totally the
wrong place
we'd had
the previous debate at the
john lockdown
about this application it was there for
a reason
so they've just gone and totally ignored
any pre-commencement
conditions particularly around the
archaeology the drainage and it's
totally
located in the totally wrong place
that's not approved
so
i think it will cause significant harm
to the immunity of the neighbouring
dwellings including lots of privacy uh
as well as noise and disturbance
the lack of consultation
is poor and that's no pun intended as
it's wet poor um
don't all have to laugh on that one um
obviously there's issues regarding the
fence uh and things like that which
should have all been dealt with before
it came here
and there's too many imponderables as
far as i'm concerned on this one and if
we did yeah
and as a late councillor used to be
honest committee says if it's not quite
right it's wrong and it is in my opinion
okay thank you very much anybody else
counter form
thank you chair
i'm also concerned about the privacy for
the residents of walnut tree house and i
concur with all the other comments that
my fellow councillors have made and i
can't support this application
thank you coach performance counselor
adam
again echoing everybody else's
sentiments entirely i also find it quite
bizarre that there's no speaker here to
speak on behalf of the application
to answer our questions that we might
have as to why they've commenced and
started and effectively finished part of
this application already uh and that the
application itself is only for the wet
poor area and not the
the furniture
upon it so that sets me off on the wrong
foot entirely in the first place so yeah
i'm with everybody else on this i think
okay thank you we've got no proposals no
seconders but what we also have to bear
in mind is we've got some good reasons
to go against the officer's
recommendation so
just bear that in mind when we're
pondering the vote
yeah if you are i'm happy to make a
proposal again i think it smacks
in the fire of
in in the face of the residents of
ignoring um
the previous agreement application lack
of consultation
and lacking of the respect of privacy so
i think we under i think it was
mentioned under cs 9 significant harm to
the immunity of neighbouring dwellings
including loss of privacy noise uh and
disturbance
and i think it's
again i've probably got this wrong one
but somebody mentioned is 10 minimized
effects on residents
um
i think there's some quite strong
conditions there
and reasons
so i propose we go against officers
recommendations and refuse
thank you very much
uh councillor dixon
i shall second that proposal
we've got sufficient reasons to make
this work um
what i'll do chair is is just um
speak back to committee about what i've
heard to try and sum them up into what i
think committee are saying in terms of
what a reason for for refusal would be
and it clearly it centers on the privacy
to walnut tree house
to the north there
and i've heard that there would be as a
result of the positioning of this
wetport play area where it is it would
intensify the use
in that particular area which then would
cause significant harm to the immunity
of the neighboring property um
and i i've heard privacy and noise those
two factors there working together
um
which would mean i haven't heard
policies quoted um specifically
but they are at the bottom of page 25
all of the policies in the ndp and
our core strategy and our spd the ones
that relate to residential immunity
so i cannot assume that members are
looking at those policies in
uh seeking to refuse this
okay okay
okay crumb are you happy with those
conditions
i'm more than happy yeah mr chairman
thank you
yeah yes
okay fine
right then gentlemen and ladies sorry
everyone say just say everything
yeah absolutely so uh
right then so we go to a vote then
please
those uh in favor of the proposal to
refuse permission
please vote
i'll go with that as well that's
unanimous chair
that's right so on that basis the
committee resolves to refuse the
planning permission
and uh
we'll await the uh
the conditions from
to refuse from
planning
are you happy to have that um
delegated to offices on the basis of the
wording i've given to committee the
actual final wording of it yes
yeah
sorry casey chrome go again
right
thank you everyone
move on to item five on the agenda
application number two one o two six
eight four stroke full treadington
little barn mana farm fossa way
treadington
invited planning officer louise casey
um
to present the application
thank you
thank you chairman
the application now before members seeks
planning permission for the demolition
of two agricultural barns and the
erection of a new dwelling
so the application site is situated uh
within the open countryside adjacent to
the foss way and is roughly 1.7
kilometers south of the village of
treadington
so the site is outlined here in red
other than the open countryside location
and the public footpath over here to the
north west oh apologies
there's no particular site constraints
and opposite the site here we can see
there's an electricity distribution site
so as it stands there's extant
permission on site to convert the
existing larger large agricultural
building to a single residential
dwelling under class q of the general
permitted development order
and in this slide here we can see an
aerial view of the site so in context to
the surroundings
and moving on to the plans here is the
proposed site layout plan uh the dashed
line on this plan just demonstrates the
footprint of the existing barn so we can
see there's an l-shaped uh proposed
dwelling on site here
turn into the elevations the top
elevation here would be the front of the
proposed dwelling which would face
towards the foss way bottom elevation
would face towards the south of the site
um the proposed dwelling would be 8.5
meters tall which is around 2.1 meters
taller than the existing barn
and here are the next set of elevations
so top elevation would be the rear and
bottom would face towards the north a
proposed material pallet consists of
concrete standing seam cladding and
vertical timber cladding
and in this next slide we've got an
artist's impression of the proposed
dwelling
and then in contrast to that we've got
an artist's impression of the existing
barn if it was to be converted via the
class q fallback so just looking back at
the proposed dwelling
and that is the dwelling as approved
under the class q legislation
is in this next slide we've got the
approved airpla elevation plans of the
barn if it was to be converted
and then moving on to some images of the
application site here we can see the
large agricultural building in the
foreground so this photo is taken just
in front of the site access
and then these next images are taken
from google earth street view so this
first image is looking towards the site
from the foss way
and then this next image shows the
northern stretch of foss way
and this final image shows the southern
stretch so it just demonstrates the
mature
hedgerow
treatment along this stretch of the road
to conclude the application site is in a
location where the development plan only
supports new housing if it provides
either a permanent dwelling for
occupation by a rural worker or where
the design and quality of the dwelling
would be exceptional as the application
proposes neither there is conflict with
the development plan however relevant to
the decision
is the existence of a fallback option to
convert the large agricultural building
to a residential dwelling officers
consider this fallback to be a material
consideration to which significant
weight should be afforded
and whilst there is conflict with the
development plan the fallback is a
material consideration which weighs in
favor of granting the new dwelling in an
otherwise unacceptable location so
chairman is therefore recommended that
planning permission is granted for
updates please see the update sheet
thank you
thank you very much louise thank you
um
right we've
we've got two speakers we initially were
going to have three but we've had
a statement sent in by the parish
council which has been printed and
passed around all the members to have a
look at um so we'll move on to our
second speaker
um
councillor
nigel rock on behalf of the residents
you have three minutes you know that
anyway and uh you'll get uh you'll get
your 30-second warning
thank you very much i i think i must
correct you though i don't think i'm
speaking on behalf of the residents
i wouldn't claim to do that i'm i'm just
speaking as an objector so
okay
um it
it's universally agreed that the
proposal for a dwelling at this site and
you've got my slide in open countryside
is in conflict with the core strategy
the sole argument is that a fallback
position exists because a dwelling is
already permitted by glint of a class q
conversion of a barn
and then it is argued it would be better
to have a new build because the barn
would not be converted to as good an
energy standard as the new build
class q is a very restricted form of
development allowing the reuse of
existing buildings
they must be of the same form appearance
size footprint and height and use the
structure of the original building
class q conversions specifically prevent
anything that could be described as a
rebuild yet this proposal is exactly
that and directly in conflict in that
principle tested in court under the
hibbert ruling
it is important the committee is not
misled by the energy calculations that
say the house
saves five tonnes of carbon dioxide a
year over the barn conversion
i have examined the energy report from
hbre in depth
while the calculation is i'm sure
correct the assumptions behind it are
not obvious
the applicants have chosen quite
different approaches to the conservation
of energy upon which the comparison has
been based
it is only those choices which give the
barn an inferior energy performance
the barn has been given absolutely many
minimum energy performance insulation
standards
and poor air cooled air leakage
the barn is assumed to have an oil-fired
boiler and no mechanical heat recovery
system
the new house conversely has materials
and techniques that exceed a superior
standard and is well sealed against
leakage
the house has a heat pump powered by
green electricity and has a mechanical
heat recovery system
i estimate if the bar had green
electrical energy a heat pump solar
panels to which is probably better
suited than the house
and any sort of improved leakage it
would more than match the house in co2
savings the solar pv alone would
generate 3.5 tonnes of annual carbon
saving
a high level of energy performance can
be achieved in a barn conversion as the
examples in the slide shows
and the middle one is a barney master
currently for sale and it's got a sap
rating better than the house that has
been applied for here
the other ones have also got very high
energy performance standards
as the sole argument is the energy
balance the comparison should be fair
and not skewed by choices of how to
construct the building
the barn can be converted to a good
energy standard and in my view it should
be
permission here on this basis would
constitute good
would constitute considerable planning
harm this proposal is in conflict with
our policies particularly is 10 and cs15
and should be refused thank you chairman
thank you council rock does anyone have
any questions
counselor mills
councillor rock
um
the facts and figures on the energy
uh
use um
where are these coming from
uh thank you councilman mills um
well there is uh an energy report that i
think was commissioned by the officers
uh to to look at that comparison
and it's been carried out by consultants
which are i've gone through it's
probably worth saying
you will know me as a counsellor but uh
before i um
retired i spent 12 years working in this
sector in energy low carbon energy
consultancy
i'm a chartered fellow at mechanical
institution and uh i have similar
qualifications too
i used to do this for a job
okay
thank you does that help oh it does
thank you
i guess i did put my hand up initially
and uh certainly uh capsule rock as
partly i think answered the question
would you regard yourself as an expert
witness
[Laughter]
before i retired yes
but i i've got old and out of date to a
degree
any other questions
next speaker is piers brooks
the agent for the uh
the project
you've got three minutes
you get a bit of a nod at 30 seconds to
go
off you go
thank you joe
our client brought the site benefiting
from extent class p permission as they
wanted to live closer to their place of
work but it soon transpired the proposed
conversion would not fulfill all their
requirements
therefore an alternative proposal has
been developed that represents their
dream home and the above slide helps to
demonstrate the differences between the
extent and proposed schemes
as noted this application is before
committee with officer recommendation of
approval and 11 public comments of
support
the committee report confirms the
principle of the developer development
is acceptable on the basis of legitimate
class q fallback position and
established case law as such policy as10
is satisfied and the proposed
development also accords with all other
relevant planning policies
as illustrated the proposed design is a
contemporary agricultural inspired form
and material palette akin to the
existing barn plus other modern barns
found within the rural context and it
does yield a 19 reduction in built form
on the side by replacing both existing
barns thereby making it less intrusive
in the landscape
the principal reason for repositioning
the dwelling further back within the
site is to address the noise from the
fast way and to provide an improved area
of immunity to the rear of the dwelling
the fenestration to the front elevation
is also restrained for this reason
viewed against the chillington hills
escarpment that slight increase in
height will not be perceptible and
especially in conjunction with the
considerable native tree planting
proposed
bordering the a429
this not only provides acoustic and
visual screening for the main road but
considerable landscaping and
biodiversity enhancements over and above
the extent class queue
in addition a large sway the wildflower
meadow planting is proposed around the
dwelling which suits our clients brief
for a low maintenance landscaping
solution whilst providing an attractive
agricultural setting
in terms of sustainability the proposed
drilling will be constructed with a
highly insulated airtight fabric and an
independent brilliant assessment
commissioned by the council confirms an
estimated 43 reduction in energy
compared with the extant class q
as for domestic cartilage this is the
same as for the extant scheme shaded
light blue on the slide and our client
is happy for this to be conditioned as
they do not want a large garden to
maintain an important point to note is
aspects such as materials landscaping
sustainability measures and the extent
of domestic heritage can all be
controlled and enforced by planning
condition under this application whereas
the class key fallback can be
implemented without adhering to any
local design requirements and without
delivering any other landscaping
biodiversity or other site-wide benefits
as an aside members will note that a
separate classical application is
currently pending consideration to
convert the existing barn into two
dwellings the reason for this
application is to extend the time scale
for the legitimate fallback position and
to ensure the value of the site is
preserved and maximized and especially
should the full application before you
be refused based upon additional
evidence that has been submitted to the
case officer to address their concern
regarding access it is expected this new
pending class application should be
granted early next week with a
three-year time spec timescale for
implementation as such we are of the
opinion this pending application should
be given material weight in your
assessment for this application and
especially as the proposal before
committee is for one dwelling on its own
in conclusion we welcome the officer's
assessment under that the proposal under
consideration is less harmful than the
extant class queue therefore it has
respectively requested the committee
grant approval for this application
thank you
thank you very much
does anybody have any questions for mr
brooks
no okay you get off that one then thank
you very much
i presume you did the drawing sorry the
the mock-up for the top right
the the cgi
generated image yes has been prepared by
us and that is a true reflection of the
approved extant elevations that louise
showed on the slide earlier
thank you very much
thank you again thank you for that
now
we were due to have the ward members
speak on this one
um but we have a substitute
um councilor rock is going to
present the uh
the ward members uh speech please
i think i'm on overtime tonight yeah
this this this time you get five minutes
or as long as it takes to be done
well thank you very much i i'm reading
from a script chairman uh and uh just to
clarify i've um
had a number of conversations with the
world member and also with the portfolio
holder for planning policy uh who have
encouraged me to um
to read this out so
these are not my words but the words of
councillor harvey who i gather as
indisposed and he's probably listening
in and would probably tell me i've read
it wrong but uh i will do my best to do
his words justice thank you chairman
um the case of this application rests
entirely
on
on extent class q approval
1903 138 coq
my understanding is the possibility of a
class q consent was intended to meet the
circumstances where a barn that had been
long since been disused
could be given a new purpose as a
residence and its useful life thereby
extended
in specified circumstances each division
judged on its own facts
such a disused barn could be converted
within its existing footprint to provide
one or more residences
a good example of a converted barn on
its existing footprint within the parish
is to be found on the eastern outskirts
of neighbouring darling skit the dutch
barn
18-00989 fuel
without the presence of the disused
treadington hills barn
had the applicant in this instance
substituted an application for a
four-bedroom house on this site in an
open countryside
i have little doubt it would have been
refused
the case officer's report in this
instance explicitly states that the
application does not comply with the
requirements of either cs15 or as10
the extent class q prior approval has
not been implemented
it is evident that it has been used as a
trojan horse for the application now
before you
having established the principle of use
as a resident
residents the applicants the applicant
now seeks consent for what was always
intended an individually designed open
market four-bedroom house unconnected
with any continuing agricultural use
not meeting any locally identified
agreed or supported need
introducing incongruous domestication
into the otherwise otherwise open south
worksheet countryside
where there are no facilities within
walking distance
and where the occupants would be
completely dependent for their daily
needs on private transport
this application relies entirely
therefore on the fallback position of
the extent to class q consent
the case officer refers to the judgment
of lin bloom concerning the materiality
of the fallback position
in particular she cites the following
in some cases that degree of clarity and
commitment may be necessary
in others not
this will always be a matter for the
decision making decision makers planning
judgment
in the particular circumstances of the
case in hand
it is for the judgment of members of
this committee with the advice of
officers therefore
to come to a conclusion over the
question of whether the circumstances of
this particular fallback development are
a material planning consideration in
determining this application
furthermore it is then for members of
the committee decide what weight should
be attached to the fallback development
as the case officer has made a point of
stressing
the weight which might be attached to it
will vary materially from case to case
and it will be particularly fact
sensitive
the case officer has also stated in her
report that weight is afforded to the
existence of the prior approval
application
this waiting can only be set as the
result of her subjective judgment
but the report neither sets out what
level of weight the officer has ascribed
nor on what
basis
subjective judgment is an integral and
necessary element of the case officer's
report
in her summation of the assessment of
the landscape impact of the applicant's
proposals
compared with that at the extent class q
approval
the officer tellingly concludes that
they are finally balanced
similarly she concludes that this
section
of her report
that only on balance am i satisfied that
the proposal would be no more harmful to
the character and appearance of the
locality and wider landscape
whilst the case officer is required to
submit her own objective judgment as the
basis for her recommendation
it is now for members of the committee
as the decision takers in this instance
to identify and to understand where and
why and how subjective judgment has been
applied by the case officer and to
question it
the committee must come to its own
judgment about where to draw the balance
over the harm caused to the locality by
either the impact of the extent class q
consent
or by the granting of the consent now
sought
to conclude mr chairman in my view there
is legitimate and reasonable scope for
members of the committee to exercise
their own judgment where it is required
in such a way
that tips these finely balanced
arguments in favor of refusing
application
in the interest of the open landscape of
south warwickshire i urge members of the
committee to do so and to refuse this
application
that time it was impeccable i was just
about to say your times
i
thank you very much i i i i believe the
um award member would be happy to
attempt to answer any questions on his
behalf as best i could having spoken to
him fine thank you anybody have any
questions for councillor rock
on what's just been said i have issues
okay just just been advised that
questions shouldn't really be asked
because you didn't write the words thank
you very much
go for a point of clarification to the
officers then please
does anybody have any
wow
that surprises me
we don't have any questions
okay thank you very much
counselor jennings
well first of all
i love the design of the of the new
house and i think it's great
however
design is a subjective matter and the
original design doesn't offend me either
of the of the barn
i mean obviously with the cgi's you got
there you got one with a range rover and
a nice neat drive and the others
overgrown with pickups in it so
that's but then again that was just done
by by the applicants so i can understand
that but i think you can make an
absolutely amazing house out of what's
there
and i've seen it many a time and you can
make these barn conversions look amazing
um
energy wise i've seen many bond
conversions which are highly
environmentally friendly so i'm not
really going with that one
and i think and it's happened a few
times we've had a few of these which
have come in
and class q is very restrictive for a
very good reason
um
it's not a free planning pass you don't
just have a barn
you get class q right knock it down and
i build something else that's not what
it that's not what class q is
um
and i'm really worried about setting
precedence
for
um other people who've got barns on
their land who've got class q
that great that's just a building plot
which i'm going to put in the middle of
the countryside
so i'm ready i'm i'm not
i don't agree i don't agree with
the way that's done so
i'm
i'm going to go and be going against the
officer's recommendation on this and i
can absolutely understand
where she's coming from on this one but
uh
um
doesn't sit right with me
and i'm happy to propose that we go
against the officer's recommendation on
this one
thank you very much again to jennings
oh
counted mills first i got him first
yes thanks mr chairman as you know
always going to look at the applications
um gosh it is situated in the middle of
nowhere um
yeah actually i totally agree with what
matt just been saying
um
not happy with this application until mr
chairman so i'll leave it at that at the
moment thank you okay thank you dixon
thank you chairman i will second the
proposal by accounts for the jennings
to refuse this application
i think when a class q gets the
opportunity to convert a barn what
should resemble in the future is a
converted barn
not a modern
contemporary in the words of the the
agent building dwelling
essentially so
i've seen a similar applications come in
on my patch where class queues have been
granted and the next thing you get is an
application to demolish and replace it's
basically a situation whereby class q
should be a conversion of a barn
so i second the proposal by councillor
jennings thank you
right now
so what
obviously we're going to overturn here
and go for reasons for refusal um
have we got those in our mind as to what
we're going to say i would say it's
contrary to the development plan and
course strategy
which policies are you thinking of there
as 10 cs 15 possibly
but essentially we i'm i would be giving
less weight
to the argument that
because you basically you're giving
significant weight to the fallback
position i think i would give limited
weight to the fallback position
just wait and see
that'll be happening so if that's the
case and you're giving limited weight to
the fallback position um the reason
would need to spell out why you're
giving limited weight to that
what planning reasons are there for
giving it limited weight what the
obviously the factors are in the report
but which ones are you looking at that
tilt balance away from what officers
have recommended i would i would
basically put
the design by itself
so the desi okay so the design of the
the fullback is better than the design
of the proposal
it's more in line with with class queue
it's more in line with the conversion
the
new application doesn't look like a bomb
conversion
okay so we're talking about agricultural
character yeah yeah okay
uh which is picked up in the report so
so yeah you're saying that the balance
isn't tilted the way officers have seen
it because the fallback is an
agricultural character which is
appropriate to this location
whereas the proposal isn't to the same
extent
okay
understood would stand out much more
so they're sufficient for us to to be
able to without sort of losing this on
an appeal or something like that and
what about going against the core
strategy on this i've already got that
in terms of
the the construction of the reason would
be effectively
the new build house is contrary to the
core strategy because of cs15 cs16 and
as10 okay in fact not cs16 so he
scrubbed that cs15 and s10
um
but then there would need to be an
explanation as to how you've considered
that fallback and and that's what
council dixon's just given me
weighed the fallback in the in the
balance but because of its design
it is actually better than the proposal
and therefore it doesn't weigh in favor
of granting the new house
and yeah as far as i'm concerned i'm
happy with with that as a reason are you
okay with that
yeah okay thank you mr chairman are you
happy with those as the reason
jennings yeah fine okay
to vote then please
we propose to refuse permission to go
against the officer's recommendation
um
for the reasons quoted that we've just
been speaking about can we go with the
vote then please
that's seven
okay
and against
abstain
one would extension okay thank you very
much
do we have any urgent business no no we
don't we have no urgent business so
therefore
the meeting is closed
you were wrong